Divine Right monarchs claimed much less
power than our current globalist Elites
because Divine Right monarchs at least
were believed that they were held in
check by God they were accountable to
somebody and they were quite accountable
to somebody because if they acted in a
way that was unjust
they were going to roast for eternity
our current globalist Elites they don't
believe that their power to rule comes
from God they don't believe in God they
don't think they're accountable at all
they think their power to rule comes
from their ability to get that power and
they've done a bang-up job of taking
power away from you in recent years and
so there are no limits in principle to
what they will do